good evening everyone welcome to the
Goldwyn theater home with the twin
11-foot Oscars I'm John Bailey I'm a
member of the cinematographers branch
and the Academy president I'm
I'm also a member proud member of the
side tech council the group that's
hosting tonight's event
as filmmakers and film goers we are all
keenly aware of how quickly new and
complex digital tools are changing the
structural underpinnings of the movies
but we need to be equally aware of how
fast this fast-moving technology is
altering the creative vision of the
motion picture artists in front of and
behind the lens we're going to focus in
tonight's programme on how this
increasingly fascinating and complex
intersection of technology and art is
also redefining the very concept of
cinematic collaboration while many
crafts are involved in this artistic
revolution in our limited time frame
here tonight we are concentrating only
on the actors visual effects and
animation these new technologies are
giving us imaginative and imaginary
characters more fully fleshed out than
ever with emotionally compelling
performances and movies today it is
truer than ever if you can imagine it
you can film it eight years ago my
fellow Academy Governor Bill Cruyff
hosted a program here that explored this
then still emerging technology back when
it was called motion capture that
technology has now become so
sophisticated and subtle in its
presentation of action and performance
that it is made possible a new world
that we call performance capture
[Laughter]
in this new style of defining character
we're actors and crew can conceive of
and create entirely new and deeply
emotive characters ones that intersect
seamlessly with our real world the
SciTech Council believes this technology
is so magical and transformative that it
warrants is taking another look at how
motion picture performance has been
transformed by these advances your
guides tonight are noted actor CCH
pounder whom we know from the iconic
film Baghdad cafe
the series the shield and NCIS New
Orleans and on to avatar and its
upcoming progeny many time sure also
with us is this year's Oscar winner for
visual effects for Blade Runner 2049
John Nelson
John also won an Oscar in 2001 for his
work on gladiator and was nominated for
both Iron Man and iRobot so now please
help me welcome to the stage CCH pounder
and John Nelson